PENG YING: Hi.
And welcome to Google
Developers Live.
My name is Peng Ying.
And with me today is
my colleague Mihai.
MIHAI IONESCU: Hi.
PENG YING: Today we're
talking about Wallet Objects.
Specifically, we're talking
about the Quick Starts
from Walllet Objects.
What we'll be doing is walking
through getting C Sharp Quick
Start up and running.
We have a variety
of Quick Starts,
but today we're
talking specifically
about the C Sharp one.
The Quick Starts are designed to
provide sample code to give you
an understanding of how the
Wallet Objects API works.
Within it, we
cover a few topics:
one is authorizing access;
inserting a new Wallet Objects
class; using the Save to Wallet
button, or Save to Wallet
JavaScript, to insert
objects; and lastly,
enabling the web service
API and discoverables,
so users can discover
your loyalty program
and join from within
the Google Wallet app.
You find documentation about
the API on our developers site
at
developers.google.com/wallet/objects.
And to show you how to get this
Wallet Objects Quick Start up
and running, here's Mihai.
MIHAI IONESCU: Thank you, Peng.
The easiest way to get started
with a sample, a C Sharp
sample, is to go to our
developer documentation
and follow the easy
step-by-step instructions on how
to get set up, download
the code, run the code,
and test it modified.
The URL, I have it right
here on the screen,
is
developers.google.com/wallet/objects/quickstart-csharp.
And you can also easily
get to the sample using
the left side
navigation controls.
We see here we have a few steps.
The first one is
get credentials,
and we have covered that in
a different Developers Live
video.
You can find that
on Developers Live,
and the easiest way
to search for it is go
to
developers.google.com/live/wallet,
and and look for a video
called Account Set-up.
And it should look
something like this.
And that will tell you how
to get your Wallet Objects
developer account
set-up, including
all the credentials
mentioned here.
So we won't cover
that in this video.
We will move right
to step two, which
is download the
Quick Start project.
We are hosting all our
samples, and demos on GitHub.
They're all open source.
You can download
them, modify them.
And in this case, the code is
hosted under the Google Wallet
repo, and I already
have it in here.
If you go to
github.com/googlewallet,
you'll find all
our Quick Starts,
and WalletObjectsCSharp
is what you want to look
for, and it's right there.
And the easiest way probably
to download the sample
is to clone it.
You can either download
the zip, unzip it,
and put the code in a
location of you're choosing,
or clone it to desktop.
And the cloning is
easily done if you're
running on a Windows machine.
In this case, you're
doing C Sharp,
so most likely you're
using a Windows machine.
You can use GitHub for Windows.
It's a very nice utility, and I
already have it on the screen.
In this case, it lists all
the repositories on the Google
Wallet, and I have already
downloaded the Wallet Objects
Quick Start sample.
In your case, the first time you
will see a clone button, just
click on it and then it'll
clone it on your machine,
and you can start from there.
So, going back to our tutorial,
once you have downloaded
the sample, make a
note of the directory
where it downloaded it.
And then, we move
to the next step,
which is configuring, and
finally building the C Sharp
project.
The best way to run
C Sharp on Windows
is to use Visual Studio Express.
You can download it for
free from Microsoft.
And once you have Visual
Studio up and running,
you can simply load the Quick
Start C Sharp project solution
into Visual Studio.
And I have Visual
Studio running here.
And if you look on the right
side under Solution Explorer,
this is how your
solution will look like.
And I will go through each
one of those one-by-one.
So first, let's
look what else we
need to have the project
correctly set up.
First of all, there
is a web.config file,
and in there we will need to
update quite a few fields.
So remember in the
beginning, I mentioned
that you need to have your
Wallet Objects account properly
set up, and after
you do that there
are a few variables that
you need to make note of,
and you will need to use those
when you update your web.config
file.
So let's start here
in this app setting
section in the
web.config file and we
have a few important fields.
The first one is the
service account ID,
which is your developer
email that links your service
accounts with your
Wallet Objects account.
It look something
like this: a number
@developer.gserviceaccount.com.
Just quickly I'm
going to show you,
you can find that in
your Cloud Console.
More details, as I mentioned,
are in the account set up
a tutorial, but
the service account
is something like
this over here.
All of those, you should
have them available
by the time you get to
the web.config file.
The next one is your
private key file.
That one you would also download
it from your Cloud Console
and rename it to something
that suits you, in this case
I just called it key.p12.
And you copy that in
the instruction for you
to copy it in the
WalletObjectCSharp directory,
and you can see
it in the Solution
Explorer is right here.
Next we have the IssuerID,
which is your Wallet Objects
developer ID.
You'll have to the
correct value in here.
Next, the application
name, that's
something all of your choosing.
Next we have origins, where
you can have a list of URLs.
Those are basically
domains where
you would run your
application on,
and the reason you
need to list them here
is that, in order to use the
Save to Wallet functionality,
the Save to Wallet button would
need to have this information
and post this information to
Google to uniquely identify
your application.
So list in here
all the URLS where
you would host your application.
And finally we have some
IDs, loyalty class ID,
loyalty object ID.
These are usually
used for debugging.
I do a lot of debugging and
you see here I have 02 in front
of it, so I change this a lot
so I can see which classes
I'm modifying and which
objects I modifying.
So these, you can leave them
as they are, or give them
whatever names you
prefer, and then they
would be listed in your
merchant dashboard.
I will get to that
a little bit later.
Once we have added and modified
all the values in here,
and everything is
correctly set up,
then we can go to
the next step, which
is loading the sample in
Visual Studio and running it.
So, I'll switch back
to the Visual Studio,
and in this case, it looks like
we're ready to run the sample.
One more thing that you should
pay attention to the first time
you are reloading the
Quick Start sample,
you may not have all the
assembly, all the library
references, set up correctly.
So in that case, so you would
go to Tools/Library Package
Manager/Manage NuGet
Packages for Solution package
In my case, probably,
it's all set up correctly,
and I don't have to do anything.
In case you need to
update the packages,
you'll get a dialogue, which
says you have some missing
packages, click Restore button
or something else to everything
up to date.
In this case, it
looks like I'm fine.
I think I built it.
It's all built up.
Let's try to run the app.
To run it you go to a Debug,
either Start Debugging or Start
Without Debugging.
Let's start debugging.
And as a webserver we're using
the local asp.net development
server, which runs
on local host,
and this is a port number.
So this is the
sample looks like.
We have two steps.
One, we provide two
buttons to insert
the loyalty class
or an offer class.
These are mostly for
debugging purposes.
You will not have
them on your website.
But are very good to
try to insert and test
different classes.
So, let's click on the first
one, insert the loyalty class.
And as I mentioned
earlier, what this does,
it will create a class into
you Google Wallet account,
and then you can verify that
that class has been created,
that how it looks like, if you
go to you merchant dashboard.
So let's switch back to
the merchant dashboard,
which I believe is here.
And you can see the
loyalty class here,
and you remember I mentioned
that I put a digit in front
of the class so that it always
pops up at the top of the list.
I have a lot of classes I've
been using for testing here.
And this is the class
we just inserted.
And if you click on
the preview button,
you can also get
a lot of details
about the various
objects inside here.
So the same if we
insert a offer class,
you can go back and verify
that this has been added,
and then you can
quickly preview it.
Now, step two is where
things get more interesting.
If I hover over this Save
Card to Google button,
you'll see that
it shows that I'm
signed in as a demo
account called John Smith.
And when I click
the button, your app
will send you some
information back to Google,
which add this loyalty card
to your Wallet account.
So let's do that.
That's quick.
So now your loyalty
card has been saved,
and you will have it
in your Wallet account,
and we'll see it later on
when we continue the demo.
Same thing with an offer.
I like an offer.
I want to get an the offer, so
we have this Get Coupon button.
I click on it,
and now the coupon
has been saved to my
Wallet, so wherever
I go I can just look at the
phone, go to my saved coupons,
and use it.
Same with the loyalty cards.
If I need to use
my loyalty points,
or just the loyalty ID
when I make a purchase,
I go to my phone and
I find it's all there.
This concludes the step one
and step two parts of the demo.
We learned how to create
and insert loyalty and offer
classes and how to create
objects of that particular type
and save them to your Wallet.
Next, we will learn how
to create discoverables.
So what are discoverables?
Discoverables are
a way for consumers
to find your program from
within the Google Wallet app.
The Wallet app has a
very wide distribution,
and this is a great
way for you to get
in front of millions
of consumers.
How do you create
a discoverable?
I will switch back to your
Wallet Objects merchant
dashboard, and on the left side
click on the Discoverable link.
And in here you'll see
a list of variables
that you have to
fill in that describe
your particular program,
everything from name,
URL, description, to
all kinds of logos,
banners, to make sure
your program very
descriptive and
appealing to consumers.
Once all that information
is correctly entered,
I will scroll down to the
end of the page, where
you see Merchant
Callback Configuration.
This is the actual website
where your web service
API will be used.
And in here you specify
the host, an HTTPS service,
with one off HTTPS port.
And inside the sample
you will fine the code
that allows you to
use the service.
This is the place where you
specify the URI endpoints where
Google will send a sign-up
and linking information
for new customers.
And with that said, let's
continue doing some demo.
So I'll pass on to
my colleague, Peng,
who will show you how it
all appears on the phone.
PENG YING: Cool.
Alright, so let's take a look
at the latest Wallet app.
I bring it up and I'm
actually on a loyalty already.
It's also logged in
with G Wallet demo,
on the same user that
Mihai was using in Chrome.
I jump to the loyalty
page, and I already
see the loyalty object
that was previously saved.
I can also see the Offers
page to see the offer as well.
In this case, it's
our demo offer,
which is Baconrista Coffee.
So, cool.
If you take a little closer look
at what was saved, all the --
man, that thing is colorful.
So now, let's take a look at
how the discoverable works.
I deleted my loyalty object.
I'm gonna add a new program.
In this case, because
currently the discoverable
is in draft mode,
we can't find it
in the list of
featured programs.
So the way that we'll
have to find it is we'll
have to click into
Add a Loyalty Program,
and enter our merchant name.
In this case, it's
Baconrista GDL.
You see it comes up directly.
So I can join as a new member.
This account doesn't have
the phone number saved,
but typically it would
be saved, so I wouldn't
have to enter it
in again, 555-5555.
Then I can just
check these boxes
and create a new
loyalty account.
So what's happening now
is that Google is sending
a message with my
information to the endpoint
that Mihai specified
and then what
that endpoint does is
it reads that message,
creates an object, and
then sends that object back
to Google.
Once Google gets that,
it then pushes the object
to my mobile device,
associated with my account,
so I can take a look at the
Baconrista rewards right here.
Cool.
So, that was a quick demo.
And to go over how
everything works,
and how all of the different
classes and things work,
here's Mihai again to talk
a little bit more in-depth
about the technical
details of the Quick Start.
MIHAI IONESCU: Thank you, Peng.
So now, let's look at some
of the most important files
or the ones you
may need to modify.
Looking at the
Solution Explorer,
we will focus on the handlers
directory, the utils directory,
the verticals directory, and
your app web page under app.js.
Let's look at app.js.
This is the JavaScript used to
generate your landing web page.
And at the top,
we see that we'll
use two handlers in here, the
insert handler and the JWT
handler.
The insert handler is
used to insert the loyalty
class or the object class.
When we click on the Insert
buttons, that's what happens.
And the handler is implemented
under the handlers directory
in the wobinserthandler file.
The JWT handler is mapped
to the wobgenerateJWThandler
under the handlers
directory, and it's
used to generate the Save to
button, save to Wallet JWT.
The javascript dynamically
inserts the JWT into the page.
Next let's look at what
wobservicehandler, which
is over here.
And the wobservicehandler
receives API requests
and responds with an approved
status and the object
to insert.
Next we have a utils
directory where
we provide a lot
of helper functions
to simplify your coding
and among those we
have tools for generating
JSON web tokens.
So it's a very handy
set of functions
that you can use over and
over to simplify your work.
And finally, the
verticals directory
contains descriptions for
your loyalty or offer objects
and classes.
And let's have a
look at loyalty.cs.
And in here we have the generate
loyalty object function,
and you look at
this file and then
look at the template
in our documentation
and see which fields
you need to modify.
For example, we have various
modules, text module data
that I'm highlighting in here.
Then down below
we have the links
module data, which contains
membership and member data,
and info module data.
So, for all of these
modules, so you
can look at the
online documentation
to find out more about them.
So now that you know
how everything works,
go ahead and download the
demo, play with it, and let us
know how it works.
PENG YING: That concludes
the C Sharp Quick Start GDL.
We hope you found
this video useful.
It's just one and many
in a series of videos
that we're doing
to help developers
like yourself get started
with the Wallet Objects API.
Be sure to check our GDL Page
at developers.google.com/
live/wallet.
And follow us on Google+.
We're Google Wallet.
And on Twitter,
@googlecommercedev.
Thanks for joining us for
another week of Google
Developers Live, and
see you next time.